if you look at the numbers today
india went from not being in the top 10
of gdp they were not a
name that was being talked about then
they went into top 10 then you moved
into number five then you dropped to
number seven
then i think right now you're number six
gdp but india's come up
walk us through the history of what's
happened to india specifically
say the last 60 years what changes has
india gone through the last 60 years
well first of all uh the gdp calculation
you are relying is on
basis of the exchange rates which
prevail in the market
uh but we economists don't use that we
use what is called as the purchasing
power parity rate
which means if i'm going to evaluate
tomatoes in my
or pizzas in my gdp
either i will use the american price or
the indian price because the quality is
the same
so the valuation goes up and we are
actually in absolute gdp
now the third largest in the world i saw
that and not fifth or sixth
which is subject to the exchange rate
the exchange rate
devalues our gdp also goes down so
i think india has come a long way
because we were really exploited
and completely drained of resources
during the british period
before that we had the islamic invasions
which
destroyed our country in many ways and
then
after the independence we began really
the bottom of the heap
and and over the years we have
we would have done gone much faster much
further had we not adopted the soviet
socialism for the first 40 years
and now in the last six years
unfortunately our prime minister is
innocent of economics so he has been
doing a lot of ad hoc things which have
failed
and if you look at our gdp graph it's
been
this growth rate has been declining
consistently is from 2016.
and now it's in minus because of the
corona but we were down to just three
percent
uh in the last quarter before the uh
corona pandemic virus pandemic came
so we need uh we can turn around
and we can grow very fast because the
amount of
potential we have is enormous i could
evaluate i
deliberate on that during the course of
the interview
but i would say that if india wanted to
overtake china it can do so and if india
wanted to challenge the united states
which is
the united states the main strength is
your ability to innovate
and bring in new innovations uh and
raise the productivity of capital and
labor
and we have shown our indians in the
united states have shown that we got as
much brains as the americans
so therefore if india were to
develop its educational system properly
uh
i think we could be a challenge to the
united states and
overtake china in the next 10 15 years
that's a pretty bold statement to make
to to say overtake china in the next 10
or 15 years which
which we'll get into that here in a
minute but prior to getting into that
you know in the u.s gandhi is seen as a
hero who is gandhi to you
atman gandhi is
was a man who actually converted the
fight for freedom from just petitioners
that we had before
highly educated people who went to
cambridge and oxford
and you know qualified at the bar of law
and uh but he may convert he himself was
of course trained in the
i mean educated in england he became a
barrister he went
and practiced in south africa for some
time but
he has completely transformed himself he
started wearing indian clothes and that
too of the poor farmer
and then he converted this fight for
independence into a mass movement
and um he had the ideas which you know
we found it very difficult
in our modern world to practice but his
uh his direction was super he wanted
india to stand on its own feet and
he thought that we had the resources to
do that which he was right
but i think subsequently his successor i
or his nominated successor
in in the government mr nehru didn't
follow anything of his
ideology and uh so he
just remains as a kind of an emotional
figure as one who got his freedom
but not that his ideology has been given
a go by
so if you like this sort of short club
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
you